[Musique]
à jouer au juste prix avec une personne
qui s'appelle sonia etc est venue avec
sa fille cynthia sonia et cynthia est ce
qu'il y à sonia et cynthia dans le
public sonia slim sa bonne étoile et moi
je maintiens mon père me rejoindre
alors ça ça c'est sonia ça c'est sonia
et ça c'est cynthia venu venu écouter
mardi à côté moi sonia merci d'être là
santé timide sonata peur de moi ou quoi
c'est vrai qu'il fait peur obama sonia
ça fait peur sonia nous tenons à lewis
et un ça va
oui merci d'être là merci merci à toutes
les deux merci à toutes les deux être là
alors sonia a trois enfants
oui tu es au chômage tu gagnes 900 euros
par mois est un souci avec tes 900 euros
par mois c'est que forcément pas de
cadeaux de noël ou pâques et de noël et
bien
sonia on a décidé de te faire jouer
parce que tu connais le juste prix le
juste prix alors cynthia est ce que tu
connais le juste prix c'est très simple
je vais te montrer une magnifique
vitrine
tu vas devoir estimer le prix de cette
vitrine en 20 secondes
120 secondes vous me donnez le jusqu'au
prix vous remportez tous d'accord on va
voir tout de suite la vie tu regardes
sans stresser d'eau
alors tous les cadeaux assure la saveur
on peut voir tata de toile
électroménager produits que voilà je
sais même plus ce qu'il ya c'est un truc
de chine voit la machine à la vie de son
mec à part de son voile alors allez
cynthia cynthia est ce que tu veux le
faire les alors enfin seconde essayé de
donner le prix de la vie à l'esa côté
cynthia les attentions alors tu me
donnes le prix de la vitrine je ne
pourrais y répondre que par plus ou
moins d'accord
attention vous me donner le prix exact
de la vitrine c'est dur 3 2 1 va seconde
passée 6 à 6 en 2010 mais deux buts 2000
plus de 1000 milles plus les ai vus 6000
et 5000 trois mois 9000 en plus et plus
d'ailleurs plus de dix mille cinq cents
plus
onze mille postes 12 + 13 + 14 mois
récents sont halal heureusement c'est
terminé et a fait une erreur a débuté
dès malheureusement c'est terminé parce
que cynthia je vais te donner et shonia
je vous donnais le prix de phèdre avril
à dans le prix de cette vitrine était
2,0 euros puisque l étape
[Applaudissements]
alors on avale aussi matelas au
téléphone qui m'a raconté que vous étiez
une super maman c'est elle qui nous l'a
dit que vous vous étiez sacrifier pour
toute votre famille et elle rêvait de
vous offrir tous ces cadeaux voile avait
avant noël et vous vous prenez voilà
vous avez tous les cadeaux là et j'ai
j'ai un petit truc à vous montrer aussi
regardez regardez vous avez regardé
l'écran
regardez on va on va remercier notre
partenaire pour l'ameublement et
l'électroménager tube regardez on est
sauvé partenaires qui vous ont offert
toute la vitrine dont on va les
remercier
voilà c'est un partenaire qui aiment le
foot vous sert visiter le magasin parce
que c'est eux qui vous ont faire la
vitrine mais si on vous montre le
magasin c'est que je sais que vous avez
que des meubles vous avez recycler chez
vous c'est ça et ben en plus des cadeaux
que vous avez dans la vitrine là vous
allez pouvoir prendre pour 6000 euros
[Applaudissements]
non et on peut applaudir sonia qui est
de ma moitié
[Applaudissements]